I feel like that there is also something
selfish and strange about the New York
life or the San Francisco life or the la
life that I've just experienced the
south and and Texas and it being a
little bit different
yeah well Texas the South in Austin are
all a little different a little
different but I understand we mean I
think that Austin has been so far let's
call it three years in three four years
in however long it is has been very
refreshing and rejuvenating in part this
is coming back to your point about our
observation of New York and LA and so on
in part because there is no one mono
conversation yeah
and that could be seen as symptomatic of
a huge benefit of living here or huge
drawback ring there's certain there are
certain locations in the world like New
York for finance in New York you have
finance yeah true in other places to say
London if you want to be in the NBA
all-star game of Finance you know it
behoves you to go to one of those
chances and as a result it attracts
people who are highly driven in certain
fields whether that's fashion finance
and so on and as you've mentioned to me
before I think it's there's a high
correlation between self-absorption and
professional success yeah on some level
it has to be and if you look at Los
Angeles
even though Los Angeles is a huge in
reality combination of different cities
entertainment is the the predominant
mono conversation whereas here in Austin
you have more of a medley yeah and
for that reason I find it I find that I
don't overtax a single sort of
conversational track or part of my brain
like you can quite easily hop from lily
pad to lily pad and maintain some degree
of mental dexterity emotional dexterity
there's just there's just more to easily
dip your toe into here yeah and it does
exist in a place like San Francisco but
it takes more effort to avoid the mono
conversations do you think one of the
downsides of the mono conversation is
also let's call it mono thinking right
so I think I think we have tended these
days to define diversity as merely a
function of race or gender but I think
diversity as far as lifestyles thinking
careers interests you know it is is also
super important the main downside of the
amount of conversation is mono thinking
and a group think that produces an echo
chamber that at least in my experience
doesn't stress test a lot of your own
beliefs because you end up succumbing to
this preaching to the choir
yeah and that I think is things very
dangerous yeah I think it's very
dangerous I think in Silicon Valley
where you have so much capital and so
much power so much culture shaping
technology that you really want to have
not necessarily a court jester but
someone who can poke fun at the status
quo and challenge deeply held beliefs or
I should say better yet deeply assumed
beliefs yeah and that is very
increasingly difficult to do in the Bay
Area yeah
in much of certainly culture in the
United States and we're in Austin yeah
which is jokingly referred to as the
blueberry and the tomato sooo yeah right
yes the blue dot in the red ocean yeah
yeah and so that it is a one might think
that Austin is just a smaller version of
San Francisco but it's not yes it's you
do have a committing of political
artistic and financial interests yes
that I deeply enjoy and the the ability
to easily for instance I mean we were
we're sitting here right above a
restaurant called Jeffrey's and next
door is Josephine house and I dinner at
Josephine house with someone I wanted to
my name most people wouldn't recognize
him but extremely successful investor a
financier who came in from out of town
came in from elsewhere in Texas very
well-educated extremely smart and also a
staunch Republican on many levels not
all levels right and it's easy to paint
with that broad brush and when you have
the ability to sit down with someone
like that easily here it becomes harder
to do what is so frequently done in San
Francisco as a place right yeah it's
been a lot of time you know almost two
decades in the Bay Area to say oh
right-wingers are all knuckle-dragging
idiots yeah it becomes much more
difficult to paint because you know my
direct first-hand experience that that's
not true it's not that it's not true in
many cases and it's just not that simple
right right it's just not that simple
and it forces you to contend with I
think a mess a reality that it behooves
all of us to recognize as messy yeah it
just requires more thought but I like
the fact that it's it's
not as easy to kind of divide this
country into like a left-right civil war
yeah
of smart versus dumb rich versus poor
this versus that it's not that it's not
as easy to do here and I like that yeah
you